oh thank an exclusive [__] white snow
man y'all know what it is chillin right
here with bootleg Capcom your what I see
it let's get tell you let's go it's hot
97 five live on the phone right now man
your boy bootleg keV rocket with you I
got that dude right now he's got a gold
album just dropped TM 103 young jeezy on
the line what's up man what up doe was
that enough in LVL me man we just
chillin the weather is beautiful
everyone you know in Vegas trying to
make a money man yeah that's what it's
all about baby sin city get to their
dollar right I gotta congratulate you my
man the album is gold you dropped and
it's like you shut everybody up when the
album drop man yeah Mel all you know we
halfway there man damn drop five weeks
out is gold but you know angle stop
there we got lost not do i gotta bring
their platinum plaque or something of
course not hey you know I'm just amped
up right now your family turned up as we
said hey I'm like I'm a big fan years
I've been a big fan since since the
mixtapes and everything if you had a lot
of haters I would say even like radio
leader radio DJs have kind of like
question you like all these guys out
make coming out you got artists like you
know Ross look you know throw some shots
as they come out number one album is
already gold how does it feel to do like
yo you ain't got it like like you're
that you're that artist that don't you
don't need the single you could drop in
cell records like I def jam victorious
play wii when you the truth it happens
like that baby you know man is the proof
is in the pudding man you know you know
anybody's been right with me says they
won or make great music Oh Melanie to
the propaganda ignore anything extra to
get that old man you know five weeks in
a gold albums ship food that man and we
still got 45 more singles on this album
to go so we just getting started and no
thought of the car you feel he needs
Robin shop yet all i do is still
climbing and you know that's one of my
was ready mix though we just drop the
remix add a feature drizzy dre yeah I
got no I got that in the inbox I wanted
to ask you cuz when that there was rumor
that that was the original record um the
original one morning nah I was always
the remake okay so y'all ready
plan yeah yells waiting on the easy
verse but I got you know it was like
damn yummy but I'm quite she's gonna
send it so when he see them put that out
too easily I can't wait to hear that man
i cannot wait to hear that yeah well ask
you a specific record we do a hip hop
show out here on wednesday nights i'll
be playing at the record somebody talked
to me will you Gibbs and then em on the
hook why did that make the album I'm the
business Baba for when I was funded on
wait on em to do a verse and I think he
was you know carve on tour he was doing
some in an arm actually what happened
man somebody leaked the record yeah I
mean before we can get the business done
and it was like my album was coming out
in two weeks who's back alone trying to
get the business done and some kind of
way between getting the record clear
that got out you know me but shouts out
the free gives you know even getting on
that man's a big shot opportunity for
you know me know I'm you know just one
of those things man but you know my god
so I would be surprised if you're you
know you hear another g z eminem vert
i'm a record yummy yeah that'd that'd be
that'd be nice a my favorite record on
the album by far strapped man that that
is so like that record is so monumental
and that that is just yeah just other
just got man you know just fit even you
know helping me put that together if you
really miss it to those words make you
all voluntary the life right now in
music you don't get that you them yeah
yeah that's what my that's why my
favorite Jeezy album is is is the
recession I mean of course everyone
loves team 101 but the recession to me
was like it was just it just spoke to
what everybody was going through at that
time like like nothing else yeah balita
know me that's what I did for me back in
already you know me like a fish outside
the gates the gears man oh he just
dropped his Marvin is my joy yeah magno
ye it means like I need you to get on
this damn lie cool he know he was our
way in which he was on Vegas last week
for my birthday party let me hear Marvin
uh he let me hear but you weren't on it
the vs. let me hear with just him and I
was like I get Gibbs are getting is red
mm amenities ma'am I am on the website
myself maybe go shoot this on you ready
for this tour me she kicked all mar 6
get ready for we go all way from Vegas
to to learn
than the friends in Paris yummy no we
are gonna shoot this neo video just
leave me alone joy nice al-mulk in 103
is gonna be a movie my mail charger
shall lose my mind shooting for me so
it's gonna be crazy so might the about
that man you know other net make no I
give my clothing line stuff together
8732 the number one urban clothes line
American hustle and get monster on the
black rough local you know our me I hear
you am last time I saw you at the palms
out here you had the live band it was
crazy are you are you touring with the
band again you doing a live band thing
on store depends it depends on the spots
like some of the spa and a few of lonely
you know I'm doing I'm doing anything to
make myself bigger than life may know I
definitely got the music know me I
definitely got the ohm you've got the
whole you know just the whole show thing
down pat I just want to make sure you
know my show is bigger than life man it
and people come out Vegas they get a
treat you know me to get to see TV a
rare form and it is like becomes their
paws man you gotta come to play baby you
know here you a lot of rappers in a lot
of rappers inland hat headline in the
palms unison leader I mama Killam on the
stage them will kill them on the crap
table you did I met at that a so there's
there's like you know there's always a
fair amount of controversy we young
jeezy you know uh you you are you're not
a man is this year to bite his tongue
and lately there's been a few artists um
out like have you heard this alley boy
dis that's that they got put out towards
us a what we're not talking any like
this record anything like that I call oh
def jam guy okay yeah sorry okay hey hey
I'll just answer that when I said yeah
Jeezy 500 def jam guy jumped in real
quick oh my goodness hey oh so I the
nude the new video when can we expect
that to come out
I made it's going to take us at least
two to three days to shoot it so on you
know I'm saying yeah give at least a
good two weeks turn around I'm gonna try
to get out ASAP because i really wanna
get the video out now you gotta lighten
up about it you got yeah i love the
record another record that that is
making a lot of noise a super freak with
two chains now he's your label may now
at Def Jam I mean he's always been on at
Def Jam you with a playing circle but
now that you know he's like the hottest
dude out and he's got the deal as a solo
artist how you feel have them on the
same team oh you know I'm actually
trying to change now you know he's one
who cashed it on riding up through the
ranks man she kind of got a respected as
like being you know an early even though
home you cannot Delmas grind man and get
his weight up man I know if you know
this time do is say man you know just
you know it is a good thing for the city
man get another cat you know go through
the ranks and as I am moving around the
world weapon his eighth year most
definitely and my last question what is
uh what is the situation with Freddie
Gibbs is he going to be dropping an
album like officially do I mean is cuz I
know he's he's with CTE I know he just
dropped his tape yesterday and freddie
is locked in right now I'm working on a
couple of things a few projects you know
i'ma say I want to I want to spill too
baby but we definitely working on it
solo and got something real nice cooking
for y'all right now you know me mr. so
it's coming out lovely so you know get a
look for that Manning in like I said you
know just a few random records
management good let me just drop the
motto going yeah you want to call it
please drop the Marvin and we got a few
more you know their job before we get to
this heat yummy yeah you guys got crazy
chemistry man i haven't heard one wet
wet record to both y'all been on yet if
my god maids are they all that there is
playing one of the others about the lv
made like a female coming through the
spirit is shake it up man when I company
ten when I come to lv led yuna stated
make you come to the show was gonna be
phenomenal March twentieth will see you
House of Blues house of blues 30 I Jeezy
may have a good day homie wat it